Rabia badate professeur
d'histoire-géographie et d'éducation
civique fait partie de la communauté
musulmane réunionnaise des musulmans
arrivaient à la Réunion depuis plusieurs
générations en provenance non pas des
pays du Golfe Persique comme on aurait
tendance à le penser mais d'une autre
ouest de l'Inde la grosse majorité des
musulmans de la Réunion viennent de la
région du guzzrate le nord-ouest de
l'Inde et je pense qu'il y a une
confusion dans les esprits puisque ce
sont des Indiens qui pratiquaient
l'islam dès le 19ème siècle quand ils
sont arrivés à la Réunion on a mis donc
ce terme arabe donc rectifions ce sont
des Indiens d'origine
du good rade c'est-à-dire un état d'une
ardoise de laine ensuite sont arrivés
les shits qui sont venus de Madagascar
après les événements de 72 donc on les
divise sur les côtes déjà les Bora et
nous avons aussi une communauté
comorienne qui vit depuis donc longtemps
à la Réunion donc voici les composantes
de cette société indienne musulmane
aujourd'hui
cette société justement forme une seule
communauté est-ce que vous avez les
mêmes pratiques religieuses alors les
pratiques religieuses sont
un petit peu différentes je dirais bon
les la majorité des musulmans d'origine
indienne sont donc des sunnites ceux qui
sont arrivés dès le 19ème siècle ensuite
nous avons les comoriens qui sont des
chafis donc c'est une autre école et
puis vous avez les Bora et les Kodia
donc c'est un petit peu différent nous
avons ensuite nos mosquées donc les
sonites ont la mosquée au centre de
Saint-Denis les sites et les donc les
Bora et les Kodia ont les leurs
actuellement au mufia il y a du parc
donc ils ont construit récemment une
autre mosquée
mais je veux dire
malgré tout on a quand même bon il y a
l'universalité du message donc il y a un
dieu donc il y a là et puis donc le
dernier prophète qui me ramène donc ça
on les retrouve dans les différentes
composantes de cette société musulmane
rayonnaise
et les femmes qui sont à la Réunion les
fameuses humaines ne vont pas à la
mosquée ici à la Réunion ce sont des
hommes qui vont voilà alors en Islam il
n'est pas du tout obligé donc
d'aller à la mosquée pour les pour les
femmes ça a été une obligation donc
instaurer pour les hommes pour des
raisons je dirais donc pratiques puisque
la femme elle est le pilier de la
famille et elle doit s'occuper justement
de ses enfants néanmoins chaque dimanche
donc on a une partie la salle donc de la
mosquée qui est
réservée aux femmes donc là elles vont
entendre des causeries et à côté de
cette mosquée nous avons ce qu'on
appelle un centre culturel alors il y a
des conférences qui sont données et là
bon la femme il va mais c'est vrai
qu'elles ne vont pas prier avec les
hommes est-ce qu'il y a pas une certaine
frustration quand même je dirais non
puisque pour l'Inde c'est une obligation
c'est une obligation d'aller à la
mosquée donc ça c'est c'est dit pour la
femme ce n'est pas une frustration je
dirais puisque elle prit exactement
comme comme l'homme et puis elle peut
donc
s'arranger comme elle veut s'occuper en
même temps bon de son ménage de ses
enfants puis elle est là elle prit mais
exactement vraiment comme les mêmes les
mêmes prières lui sont indiqués
doit être étudié dès le plus jeune âge
par l'enfant alors après vers l'âge de
10 ans donc il fait ce qu'on appelle le
il termine son Coran donc c'est un
moment important de sa vie et vous avez
des jeunes qui aujourd'hui
étudient donc ce Coran par cœur
par rapport au père ou ça se fait d'une
façon
occidentale je veux dire ou alors il y a
aussi la tradition qui a sa première
place alors dans je dirais la femme
musulmane a des droits à des droits et à
des devoirs d'abord en tant que fille
elle est bien
respectée protégée par le père les
frères ensuite quand elle est épouse
elle est respectée par le mari donc ça
c'est dit dans le dans le Coran je
répète il y a donc un chapitre réservé
pour pour ça et puis il y a des radis
donc les traditions des prophètes
alors on nous dit le meilleur parmi vous
est celui qui est le meilleur envers son
épouse donc ça c'est Hadit et un petit
peu plus loin on rajoute pour la mer le
paradis se trouve sous les pieds de vos
mères donc la place également de la mer
alors maintenant bien évidemment l'un
des deux devoirs le devoir essentiel
c'est de donner une excellente éducation
à l'enfant donc ça c'est le rôle de la
mère dès le plus jeune âge elle doit
mener de front les deux éducations
c'est-à-dire
inculquer les bases de l'islam donc elle
va inscrire l'enfant la médiation à
l'école coranique et puis après donner
aussi une excellente éducation pour que
l'enfant puisse insérer dans la vie je
dirais active plus tard ça c'est son
devoir et puis donner aussi les valeurs
je dirais morales à cet enfant le bien
le mal le partage le partage
œuvré pour servir donc il faut que dès
le plus le plus jeune âge on apprend
ceci à l'enfant et son des tâches qui
incombent à la mer
mais je dirais aux filles la mère inclut
toujours les valeurs
traditionnelles retransmettre les
recettes de cuisine qui nous ont été
légués par nos grands-mères on continue
je dirais le faire moi j'ai deux fils et
puis donc une petite fille elle n'a que
12 ans mais elle commence à préparer la
cuisine indienne donc sur les valeurs
que nous allons continuer à transmettre
et je pense que c'est important pour
pour un enfant de ne pas perdre
justement toutes ces racines et d'être
attaché donc à des cultures différentes
ce qui fait la richesse d'un enfant du
temps de votre maman il y a eu une
certaine éducation comme pour tout le
monde et il y a eu une évolution quand
même par rapport à aujourd'hui est-ce
que pour vous les femmes musulmanes
est-ce que vous ressentez ça très fort
est-ce que ça a été très difficile pour
vous justement de ne plus être comme
maman
oui bien évidemment il y a eu une
évolution très importante par rapport à
ces femmes qui travaillaient et qui
travaillaient beaucoup dans l'ombre qui
nous ont permis d'être ce que nous
sommes aujourd'hui donc qui nous ont
inculqué toutes toutes nos valeurs
nous sommes bons des femmes
actives qui ont bon ben
tous les problèmes que rencontrent
toutes les femmes mais on essaie
justement de les surmonter je veux dire
c'est vrai qu'il y a eu une aide
évolution par rapport à ces femmes qui
restaient à l'intérieur là il faut
concilier les devis donc sa vie
familiale et sa vie active alors sont
des jeunes qui sont souvent très longues
mais on arrive à les assumer je pense
que toutes les femmes de la Réunion sont
les femmes qui sont extrêmement
courageuses et qui arrivent à
équilibrer leur vie lors de la vie
à l'intérieur du foyer et la vie bon à
l'extérieur ce n'est pas toujours facile
il faut essayer de préserver donc cet
équilibre entre tradition et modernisme
donc la femme elle jongle avec ses deux
modes de vie donc il y a la tradition
qu'elle doit préserver et passer le
relais je dirais ensuite aux enfants
puisque c'est la mère qui transmet
toujours les traditions et toutes en
ayant donc ce côté de le moderne de la
vie donc s'intégrer dans la société
une intégration grandement réussie dans
les milieux sociaux économiques
politiques juridique et qui se
traduisent notamment pourra bien par des
actions au sein de l'association
musulmane de la Réunion une communauté
qui participe totalement à la ville
locale comme ici lors de la réception
annuelle donnée par la mairie de
Saint-Denis
alors sont invités
musulmane réunionnaise donc dans chaque
commune de Lille on organise
tous les ans une fête après le mois du
Ramadan et là on invite tous les
composantes donc à la mairie de
Saint-Denis on a l'habitude juste après
le ramadan ou alors pour la fête
d'Abraham d'être nous sommes accueillis
par le maire de Saint-Denis est-ce que
c'est important de le faire oui je pense
que c'est important justement puisque
c'est quand même un moment
bon de joie qu'on doit partager avec les
autres donc puis c'est un moment de
rencontre aussi ça permet de mieux
connaître aussi les uns et les autres et
habituellement les gens qui sont invités
répondent d'une façon positive ils
viennent oui il participa donc les gens
viennent comme on a vu la fois dernière
oui c'est quand même bien suivi
dans votre association votre rôle à vous
c'est quoi alors moi je m'occupe je suis
la vice-présidente maintenant depuis
quelques années on a créé une commission
femme puisque souvent les femmes ont des
problèmes
c'est plus facile de discuter de nos
problèmes entre des femmes je m'occupe
également de la culture et de
l'éducation donc quand nous recevons un
conférencier par exemple on va organiser
pour donc l'accueil ensuite on mène
également sur le terrain bon il y a des
femmes qui sont en difficulté on va les
aider
puis souvent des fois il faut seulement
écouter donc et puis conseiller l'autre
qui est en difficulté on connaissait de
d'être présente quand elles ont besoin
de nous et cette échéance se fait
uniquement entre musulmane ou non je
dirais non pas seulement que musulmane
moi je suis donc sollicité par je ne
considère pas seulement bon il n'y a pas
que la femme Jules marins sont toutes
les femmes réunionnaises quand elles ont
des difficultés elles peuvent nous
appeler et nous sommes là pour justement
les aider quand je travaille dans un
collège j'enseigne à tous les enfants il
y a pas que bon il faut justement qu'on
aille au-delà de ces frontières il y a
pas donc la communauté musulmane
chinoise est un moule tous les
Réunionnais doivent vivre justement en
harmonie et s'entraider pour l'équilibre
de notre pays
alors je dirais au-delà donc des
religions
il faut qu'on arrive à la Réunion donc
on soit chrétien mais je le mens
d'amour qu'on arrive donc à vivre bien
ensemble c'est avant tout l'être qui
compte et bon je veux dire quelque soit
la femme quel que soit donc l'homme nous
devons nous entraider travailler
ensemble pour un mieux être
de tout sur cette île